now
she's considered the guardian angel in
the hispanic community a woman who
connects the uninsured underinsured and
the undocumented with life-saving
resources as part of hispanic heritage
month we profile veronica gutierrez
salazar
a special recognition for veronica
gutierrez salazar by her colleagues at
the engelstep foundation red rose
program surprising her with the acts of
human kindness award she is so
empathetic she's so kind she's so warm
when it comes to really making sure
people feel supported red stands for
responsible early detection in the fight
against breast cancer i'm very blessed
because
that is not a solo achievement it's a
teamwork veronica salazar gutierrez
fulfills our adrian dominican sisters to
me it's just keeping that emotional
connection to just pushing motivating
and just they can make it and there is a
place and a people a person that care
about them the red rose program of
dignity health saint rose dominican
provides free screenings clinical breast
exams mammograms ultrasounds and
surgical consultation to women and men
who lack adequate health resources or
the financial means to obtain them
education everybody can learn about
early detection that this cancer is
intimidating
world
but it's like any other disease that if
you
can detect early you can
treat it
but also there is a resource she is
considered as angel de la guardia or
guardian angel
she's seen as someone who guides people
and make paths to people so they are
connected to resources she has become a
pathway to a lot of the women that we've
been helping i think her impact in the
community
is just tremendous she is so amazing at
what she does i would love that
everybody
as soon as they hear red rose
they know i know it's the
flower and the program for the breast
cancer that should be my this is my goal
the red rose program fields about 200 to
400 calls a month their renewed focus
that breast cancer is a disease that
impacts the entire family unit they're
encouraging the male figures and
households to dedicate more time to make
sure all the women in the family get
services for early detection and
necessary treatment if needed